ils ont les yeux fatigués mais le
sourire aux lèvres
et pour cause cette quinzaine d'enfants
biélorusse vient de passer la journée à
disneyland paris
j'ai beaucoup aimé le château de disney
la montagne russe
l'ambiance les personnages tous ces
enfants sont originaires de la région de
gomel une zone encore sous surveillance
depuis la catastrophe de tchernobyl
grâce à des familles d'accueil bénévoles
de l'association espoir à tchernobyl ils
découvrent pour la première fois la
france
on est allé à paris donc elle a eu tout
paris ja il faut avec nous l affût paris
de nuit aussi s'est tue la liberté
qu'elle voulait impérativement voir pour
oksana comme pour les autres enfants
ce séjour c'est comme une parenthèse
dans un quotidien difficile
c'est un milieu bon on leur parle
souvent de maladies ils ont été ils ont
été malins ils sont entourés de gens qui
ont été malades
donc ils vivent dans une certaine forme
de stress donc vu sortir de leur milieu
voir autre chose ça leur ouvre l'esprit
ça les détend
je pense que ça leur apporte beaucoup
sur le plan physique et sur le plan
moral
les enfants sont repartis dimanche après
trois semaines d'immersion dans la
culture française dans leurs bagages de
beaux souvenirs et les rudiments d'une
nouvelle langue